só para 20 e hoje vou ensinar como fazer
uma granada da stop usando um ovo do
plástico é bastante simples encontrar
vocês podem ver melhor o tutorial para
53 são bastante simples vocês vão ter um
exclusivamente em casa mas quando vocês
forem usar vocês devem usar outros
proteção porque constitui uma jornada
normal da ir só vi quando o sporting
manda bolinhas por todo lado até então
pronto é usar óculos de proteção
é isso então vamos agora aos testes pois
o tutorial passo a passo fora
então vamos lá pessoal primeiro tem que
falar no folha com os fosse uma rifa é
que ela das férias
caso vocês não conseguirão fazer isso
direito vou deixar um link de inscrição
onde ensina a fazer isso mais jogar o
passo a passo
depois tem que ir lá como foi a volta de
moda fazer muito bem importado é justo
tudo e prenda com fita para não ser lá
para finalizar tem um país grande e
prendendo um lado para o outro
pega no vosso o ovo e marca em altura no
tour depois corta geralmente mais
pequeno para outubro depois que caiba
dentro do hockey quarta em dois domingos
iguais e têm que fechar uma das partes
da queda tudo eu vou usar fita mas vocês
podem usar qual é o celular o presidente
fica uma das partes chatas
pôxa passado elástico e enrolado em
várias vezes a volta até que fica assim
nem executado em solta assim mais ou
menos ok vamos fazer um boxe e que está
estava tudo pois houve briga por vaga em
casa no se encaixar tudo vai agora fazer
o resto eu vou aqui lugares este
orifício para por um elástico e fazer
uma espécie de trava de segurança ok
para que o ovo não abra quando você não
estiver em usá-lo quiserem podem ser
dois elásticos fica ainda mais
acho que tenha alguma vez só uma garrafa
e vou fazer dois orifícios em lados
opostos no gelo em uma argola fazer o
braço mecânico encontrar e prender para
cima até parece que foi mesmo feita por
fazer granada com aquela para o duelo
direitinho claro um pesado de bolinhas
faz vocês não encontrem a venda é assim
eu contei vai comprar aí muitas muitas
um saco grande tem quase um quilo por 33
euros de euros
então é só encher os tubinhos agora se
vocês quiserem podem pôr mais domingos
lá dentro podem por quatro clubes mas
não sai às vezes elas encaravam na outra
se vocês quiserem duas ok então escolher
o que quer mais eficaz usarem só dois
clubes
joaquim como é que vocês aprendem
esquema de segurança pronto já estava
pronto a usar você joga um período até
que o encaixe e pronto
agora só falta eu sou falsa significar
um perigo já que eu tinha lá dentro mas
tem todo direito de ir e vir o outro o
tomate ficou super sensual estagnada e
estão digamos oficial
espero que o estado só vocês quiserem
usar o canal e fecharem um laico e se
inscreva para acompanhar essas coisas
que o fato tiverem mais sugestões de
projetos alexandrino inscrição é que o
tento fazer e eu pensei que isso era
impossível fazer nada vocês propuseram
então eu tentei ninguém foi igual ao que
ele só conseguia criar
então é isso aí só obrigado até a
próxima se ao